hey guys I'm buddy from gamespot
universe and this is a double purpose
video we're going to go over what and
where the Infinity stones are in the
greater Marvel Universe and what the
stones do in Capcom's latest fighting
game by the way I'm about to say
infinity and stones a lot can't be
avoided but if you got a problem
bring it since the reveal of the
Infinity stone feature in Marvel vs.
Capcom Infinite which is a returning
mechanic from the original Marvel Super
Heroes in 1995 we have been waiting to
see what each stone does in the game
though the Infinity stone mechanic has
the same name as its predecessor the
effects are entirely different in the
comics the Infinity stones each have two
power settings alone they're powerful
but when they're together with their
infinity gem counterparts in the
Infinity Gauntlet
their power becomes devastating Capcom
seems to have taken inspiration from
this while creating the mechanics for
the stones giving each two power levels
a basic usage of a stone is called an
infinity surge hitting the stone button
activates a unique ability for each
stone the higher-level usage called
Infinity storm activates a more powerful
ability and drains half of the Infinity
stone gauge which is filled on taking
damage or using the basic Infinity surge
ability before we give in to comic-book
geology be sure to check out GameSpot
universe where we cover all other things
that gamers love that our games like
movies TV shows comic books and plastic
toys alright let's get rocked in the
comics the mine stone gives its user
telepathy telekinesis and can enhance
the existing mind powers of its user
when used in the gauntlet it connects
the users mind with all other minds in
the universe the mine stones infinity
surge uses the telepathy aspect to throw
your opponent and briefly render them a
mobile it's infinity storm causes your
hyper gauge to rise continuously for the
duration allowing you to execute a
ridiculous string of combos
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe the
mine stone is currently residing in
visions face the bearer of the Power
Stone has increased strength endurance
and invulnerability with its infinite
power it's the most sought-after battery
in the Marvel Universe
while paired with the other stones it
actually boosts their effects in the
game it's infinity surge provides a
powerful attack with knock-back and it's
even more powerful infinity storm
ability raises your attack power in
addition to the knock back on every
attack okay so the Power Stone raises
your power we get it good job in the
film's the guardians of the galaxy gave
the stone to the Nova Corps for
safekeeping after taking it from Ronan
the dead guy the time stone gives the
user the ability to time travel a Jordy
Age people see the past or future and it
can trap people in time loops while in
the gauntlet it allows its user to exist
at all points in time simultaneously the
time stones infinity surge ability
allows you to manipulate time by moving
its super speed for a set distance the
stronger infinity storm ability
increases your speed when switching
characters and allows you to change
successful hits into other attacks after
the events of the Doctor Strange film
the time stone is waiting in kamar Taaj
in Katmandu Nepal the space stone allows
for teleportation speed increase and the
ability to create wormholes between
locations while in the glove it allows
the user to be everywhere at once
drawing on the location manipulation
abilities of its comic book counterpart
the space stone surge draws your enemy
towards you it's infinity storm ability
creates a force cage around your
opponent restricting their movement up
and over Loki use the space stones power
to open up a portal that allowed the
Chitauri to invade New York City
thankfully the Avengers kick their asses
and Thor returned to Asgard with the
stone and his problem child brother with
the dumb helmet the reality stone allows
the user to do whatever they want in
their current location while used in
conjunction with the other stones the
user can change the reality of the
entire universe the reality stones
infinity surge creates an energy burst
that tracks your enemy is it
closes in on them it's stronger storm
ability causes a different elemental
attack depending upon the button pressed
in Thor the dark world the reality stone
is known as the aether it is pulled from
Jane Foster into the Dark Elf male cthe
who wants to use it to destroy basically
everything male kith is stopped by Thor
and the stone is given to the collector
for safekeeping in the comics the soul
gem gives the power to manipulate steal
or alter living or dead souls the gem
itself is actually sentient and hungers
for souls the souls are kept in a heaven
like pocket universe that exists within
the gym itself when paired with other
gems it allows for control over all life
in the universe the soul stone is
currently missing in both the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite but there have been numerous
rumors as to what the soul stones
abilities will include based on what the
stone does in the comics and what we've
heard the stone surge ability will add a
passive life steal from your partner and
it's infinity storm will allow you to
revive the partner that you just sucked
the life out of pretty damn cool while
we're just guessing all sources point to
Hell of possessing the soul stone in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe she is the
goddess of death so it would make sense
that she's out there stealing souls the
collector's edition of the game which is
out September 17th comes with all six of
the Infinity stones in a decorative case
along with a 20-17 character pass
through the game and statues of chun-li
Mega Man X Iron Man and Captain Marvel
if you liked this video you can always
get more about your favorite comic books
TV shows and movies at GameSpot universe
thank you so much for watching I love
you now I'm going to try to do with
Thanos impersonation ready right mMmmm
he doesn't make that noise sorry but
does that face